sure sure maybe maybe you had a good  experience of marriage in your family  but that's not everyone like some people  watched their dad get taken to the  cleaners right some some men have like  watched their dad commit suicide some  some men thought that their their dad  was a deadbeat just to find out he  wasn't allowed in their life after 20  years and so it's like what are those  guys supposed to do sign the same  contract they watched everyone else get  wrecked by I was in a 10-year  relationship  and it doesn't mean he doesn't love the  girl could have been classes of marriage  but even after going through that and  having the the isms and the schisms that  happen after that when you've got a  child with somebody etc etc I was like  imagine if I was married like I'm having  these problems without being married  imagine if I was married